hello okay microphone works okay I have
a lot of slides we don't have much time
i'm also very very tired because i came
just yesterday and i slept like four
hours and some hours on the plane and
you know plane flights it's never good
sleeping you just drool on yourself and
you just type that there in the water
talking about the water i want to talk
about today a bit about how we are we go
a bit overboard with the javascript that
we're doing right now because javascript
has been such a massive success the last
few months that we all get very excited
about it and I find it kind of
frustrating how people feel out of sync
or feel not appropriate anymore and how
the JavaScript community becomes a bit
arrogant and aggressive and I think it's
not necessary that we do that to
ourselves or to other people as we've
been asked to introduce ourselves a bit
to the camera and the recordings I'm
going to talk a bit about myself but
it's not gonna be the normal like hi I'm
here and I'm sorry it does it mean but I
want to give you a bit of a frame of
mind why I came to be Who I am here and
why I think that we're going a bit
overboard so I'm Chris Hyman I'm at code
poet on Twitter so if you don't have
enough hedgehogs fluffy animals and
JavaScript information in your world you
can always follow me there I think fifty
one thousand people do that right now so
don't be surprised if there's a lot of
answering and stuff going on and I don't
know why people do it but it seems some
of the things I do are interesting I
live in London England and this is what
my street looked like last week
basically grim and terrible that's why
we do so many things with computers most
of time it rained since when people
start drinking and fighting that's why
you stay inside and write JavaScript
instead it was also seven degrees and
now it's like 24 here or something and
I'm just going in between I'm going to
Thailand after this and Sydney because
they're going to try out what happens
when you put redheads in the Sun and
then I hope back to England and go to
Finland after this so if I not get a
cold it's going to be a very big
surprise I've been a developer right to
present a trainer and manager and all of
this is
cause I know JavaScript and I think it's
very important that all of us here stop
thinking about that sooner or later
you're gonna be as old as me your hair
is gonna fall out you're gonna not have
fun in life any longer and you're going
to think about your long-term plan of
what you're doing so thinking about I'm
the best engineer on this planet and I'm
going to do that for the next 50 years
is not a good plan but as we build a
community around our technologies and as
we build as we work in a medium which is
the internet and we don't work just in a
software platform we have a chance to be
all these kind of people so in 2004 I
wrote this unobtrusive JavaScript
tutorial how to write JavaScript that is
not in the way of your end users in 2006
i wrote my first book i've i think it
published or written in eight books so
far or something like that and thousands
of articles basically because when i
write things down i remember them my my
blog started as a scratch pad for my
ideas because i wanted to remember them
which is very very annoying if forget
something and i go to google and i find
my own blog is the first result because
i just realized i get forgetful but this
is what we all do so i worked in several
companies and large corporations and i
work with javascript in all these
corporations and did things to scale and
did things to two different audiences to
different markets and i found out that
way that javascript is a very very cool
and versatile thing I worked for Yahoo
and I worked on the way I library i
worked on your home apps i worked on
yahoo answers and there you hear things
like oh we got three thousand people a
second what do we do about this in terms
of architecture be like okay let's try
that out then I worked for firefox and i
worked on firefox OS which was very very
low level devices that were running an
operating system written in HTML 5 for a
market that is not in the Silicon Valley
and it is not rich kids and now i'm
working for microsoft and work on a new
edge browser because I basically
realized that internet explorer is the
reason for all of our unhappiness and I
should be in the company that built that
thing and replace it with something good
and that's what we did right now always
go for the source don't go for fighting
symptoms find out if you if you're sick
find out what made it happen not take
painkillers
and hope it's going away so that's what
I did with Microsoft I'm very happy
about that and I use JavaScript in many
many different environments altering
websites and enhancing them with GS of
course the first thing that's why
javascript came around and that's why
javascript was used and I think it's
very important to realize that enhancing
them with jas is a big big thing here
because websites are more than a
JavaScript construct websites or HTML
CSS images writing accessibility UX
these are things that are publications
on the web and the web is an undefined
environment I cannot control anything
that our end users are doing so if it
runs fast on my machine well done if you
your only user that's great but think
about the people who are out there as
well we also had scripting and extending
applications that started with
illustrator I wrote JavaScript an
illustrator that was possible in 99 and
then home side was my big editor back
then it was written in jscript which
raised the terrible thing that should
never happen but did then Visual Studio
code for example now came out yesterday
as open source Adam is another travel
script editor that is written in
JavaScript with node and sublime text
has all kind of extensions that you can
write with it as well so we wrote in
environments like applications before
and for the web and these are two
different environments and two different
rules and two different best practices
apply to those and authoring reusable
widgets for people who don't know
JavaScript I mean later on this became
jQuery plugins but before that we had
like d HTML drop-down menus in these
wonderful things like when you got like
six on a pound for 40 lines of
JavaScript that when you look at them
now you want to kill yourself working on
libraries and frameworks on Yui on
jQuery on dojo on all these things that
came and went when I wrote for a Jackson
as a blogger at one time there were 400
12 different Dom libraries that all made
Ajax easy now we have was like 15,000 no
180,000 NPM modules that make everything
easy as well it might be a different
world that we're living in right now but
also we ride a lot of code that other
people will never use working on
browsers and JavaScript engines gave me
a lot of insight how javascript is
actually going into the computer how
it's turned into bytecode what the
browser does to us and what we do
terrible things to the JavaScript engine
and then blame the browser makers that
they write kara crab code and working on
server side JavaScript using no chest
this is a really really great thing that
we can now write a server with a few
lines of code and we can host the thing
in the language that we're done before I
moved most of my PHP work to note
because it's just easier for me to do
nowadays although it's damn easy to get
a PHP server not as easy to get a node
server going and designing a P is for JS
consumption as well when i worked on
yahoo yql or on pipes and I help people
like encoding calm as fortify and all
those people that want to talk to
JavaScript developers how do you define
an API for JavaScript developers all of
that taught me that javascript is a
versatile creative and easy-to-learn
pick and mix environment it is basically
it's it's a sweet shop it's a beautiful
thing because you can use that language
for almost anything and when you use it
you apply it in a certain way you don't
apply it in just one way to rule them
all but we keep treating JavaScript like
a one-size-fits-all environment that we
can control it works for me our our
users should have the newest browser as
well all of our users should actually
have a faster computer because it's
their fault that my code is slow and we
really like this kid we just scream and
shout at each other and we scream and
shout about everything that we use while
we are actually having incredibly good
hardware an incredibly good development
environments when I look at dev tools of
chrome dev tools of Firefox and soon dev
tools in edge I'm just amazed what we
can do nowadays what kind of insight we
get and still we're saying like Otis is
not as good as the other environments
although most of us never looked at the
other environments and just looked under
the hood just how horrible Android and
iOS is as well because it's software
it's written by humans it's written by
people like us who just clean other
things and then like look it's working
I'm not going to look at a name all and
I think lately we go overboard with Jess
we just try to do everything with Jess
and we get terribly excited if if it
works and we get terribly disappointed
if not everybody is with us on that on
that same boat we're going full speed on
innovation I'm not going to
go into the details but if you subscribe
to a co je s or you go to hack and use
every day there's some new thing every
three months one of the large
corporations will have some great new
thing that will be the future of the
internet and then half year later we
won't hear about it any longer and all
of these things are incredibly important
things they're incredibly intelligent
things very well architected things but
many of them are also like is it really
necessary that we all play on the
bleeding edge because the bleeding edge
is about this wide we would fall over if
all of us played there and it's bleeding
so it's hurtful so the code that is on
the bleeding edge should not hurt our
users but should move us forward so we
should find time and space to use it and
not just say this is the bleeding edge
and it's now they've now the reality
it's a vicious innovation cycle
developers don't use features until
browser support them and browsers don't
add new features unless there's demand
and use in the wild this is how every
browser maker prioritizes new features
do people really use these things oh no
they don't so we don't have to have them
and it's a very important thing because
browsers are also software developers
it's a finite number of people even the
open-source ones have a finite number of
people working on those things so that
cool new feature that you really want is
it necessary is somebody using it no we
all know that app cache is broken it's a
terrible thing Jake Archibald said it's
the end of the world and it killed
kittens and all kind of stuff and then
when you when you send out the ping
crawler ping is a search engine you
could go before that if you don't know
it and we look at the mag Adam to
standards inside Firefox we found out
that hardly anybody including
applications used in app cache people
just saw it's broken and never tried it
out so at the same time we just had this
like oh we're not going to touch it
because it's so terribly broken I tested
it myself no you didn't you're lying
because it otherwise it would be on the
web somewhere and developers just want
the new shiny things rather than
demanding the things that are broken
form elements are still terrible across
browsers you cannot start a select boxes
you cannot a datepicker Lou
doesn't work on all browsers the same
way and it that's fine they can work
differently but it should work and not
just be something that is in the browser
because it's there we should demand more
that the basics of HTML 5 is working
before we're going for the next feature
out there and we force rules on to
ourselves that might be overkill I love
this blog post the other day that's the
checklist for a new open source
JavaScript project please follow these
steps and you know if I were now
somebody coming from University I never
been to university or somebody coming
from school and saying like I want to
learn something about that computer is
thingy where all the jobs are and people
get money and I get this instead of like
here's the SDK of iOS I probably would
go for iOS as well because that is too
much all of these things are important
all of these things are well architected
all of these things are beautiful but
putting them all together is just
shocking new people and stopping them
from getting into the market because
this is not inviting this is just
telling people here is how it has to be
done and this is why i left germany and
move to England because in Germany
everything is this is how it has to be
done we live in a high fueled
environment we don't even want to
deliver things anymore we just get
excited about ourselves the the tech
press has nothing else to write about
but javascript and developers at the
moment almost every tech company sees
developers as the audience that we try
to get to cause the audience for our
users of our products that stuff that
happens magically or so we hope but
developers are the most expensive thing
to get right now and hardest thing to
get as well but the only market where
there's more jobs than people for now
there will be a crash there was a crash
in 1999 when I we lived in when I lived
in Los Angeles that it will come again
it cannot be retained so I'm like 18
billion dollars for a company that
allows people to send emojis to each
other there's something going wrong
there but right now we are could we are
basically up in demand and people really
really want us and it's all about hype
it's a set of saying like okay I want to
build something beautiful for you that's
maintainable I'm like I can make it a
coolest newest thing using these 12
frameworks like writing that you know
about your ex that you know how to make
an accessible web app on your on your CV
will get you much less than saying
like I know the framework so in so
that's right now in half the demand I
love these linkedin invites when people
ask for three year experience or five
year old libraries but that's a sign of
that hype that we're having right now
which is trying to impress each other
and the prayer and the tech press is
just making everything amazing you know
everything is like just a new library
dust is it's only so small it's so
amazing it does this and this and this
and this don't use in production so what
do we use it for like impressing each
other playing with it at home this is
not really what we're going to do we're
impressing one another rather than
building things for the outside world
and this is most like most of time
people like to quote Moore's law and
this is a bit paraphrased is normally
about semiconductors and pricing of
those computers get faster better
cheaper and more available every two
years and I hear that every time when
something is slow yeah but the new
iphone is coming out it will be fine
then you know because my javascript
library is probably the thing you want
to buy an eight-hundred-dollar phone for
so it actually works faster and
everybody just expects continuously
people to upgrade their computers
because we do we work with amazing
hardware most of the companies are not
flinching anymore when I say like I want
to get a macbook pro I got a macbook pro
for Microsoft when a joint them as my
computer and assembly to test the test
things out because they know not
everybody uses windows in the developer
world and I used to Mac before so I
wanted to stay with that as well we have
phones that are amazing we get test
phones we get to try things out we also
work with amazing connectivity like
compared to the outside world there and
I staying in hotels a lot I know how bad
connectivity can be and living in
England at times as well we work with
great connectivity and what does that
blink anyways we work with great
connectivity in an environment where we
don't even know what elf line is anymore
and most people out there that don't
have that we get paid well for a job
that we like to do and start talking to
people outside our market if they get
paid for the job that they like to do or
if they have more fun in their free time
and it just go to work to make money and
that's something we should never forget
how lucky
we are how amazingly lucky we are that
we get the freedoms that we have the
problem is though that we assume all the
things that we have other people have as
well we work with these beautiful
browsers and all of them are amazing yes
even the ones on older androids yes even
Safari yes even know Internet Explorer
as dead edge is great all these browsers
have come with amazing tools and all
these browsers have at least a baseline
that we can now work against and when I
started as a web developer that baseline
wasn't there that's what we fought for
this is what the web standards movement
was about that browsers follow standards
and compete on the on UX and compete on
the features that are for end-users and
not on the engine that drives those
browsers when we talk about Moore's law
we have to talk about mais law which is
again paraphrase but it says software
efficiency halves every 18 month
compensating for moves Moore's law
meaning the longer you maintain a piece
of software the bigger it gets in the
slower it gets and we all been there I
love that it's two years for software
for hardware to get faster an 18 month
for software to get slower so some will
be losing six months all the time so in
essence we move fast and we run in
circles because we have good stuff and
we put more things in and then we wait
until the hardware catches up again and
then we write more stuff again I talked
earlier to somebody outside i noted with
hard drives you know you upgrade your
hard drive from 100 gig to 250 cake and
then like oh that's going to last me for
the next three years four weeks later
there's like 10 gig left and you're like
what did i do you have 6000 NPM modules
thousand eighty resolution movies
instead of CM 920 resolution which is
with digital hoarders we love to fill
things up because we might need it later
on the same way in our products we use
all the things that in the future our
users might want to have rather than
building something simple and making it
after feedback from the users making it
better the web is in a sorry sorry state
and that is really annoying me because
the behb the web made my career I don't
have a job education I didn't finish
university without the web but would be
probably I don't know what I were doing
dancing at cafes or something
the median web page time to interact is
5.5 seconds and fully loads in just over
15 seconds and that was a there was an
analysis / web performance daily had
been done I've been done there the
median web page is to megabyte in size
and contains 170 resources it is if it
is if like we didn't have any
performance information or training or
tools and browsers for years and years
who builds this stuff it cannot be us
because we learn all these cool things
here right must be some idiot that does
it differently but it's us it really is
over time because we move on to the next
library that we try out and we move on
to the next project that we want to have
and we believe companies when the
software becomes unmaintained well we
don't want to keep it any longer and
then instead of fixing it when we go to
a new job we just show them the new
framework that we came with that will
make everything better again right
waiting isn't fun it's not fun to look
five seconds on your phone people don't
do it they basically after two seconds
on the phone we have much less patience
than we have on the desktop on a desktop
you got 12 tabs open you go to the other
tab you look at fluffy kittens and you
come back to the other one that loaded
on the phone you like I'm gonna kill you
or like is it come disconnected again
the amount of times i call my isp that
something is wrong where it realities
was just a website slow yeah well they
deserved it it's especially annoying
when it costs you i just arrived
yesterday and three my provider in
England says it's a max of two pound of
minimum to call one point 25 to receive
a call six pound per megabyte to use the
web and email this means the average
website is the same as the same price as
a ticket for the cinema so I really hope
that your website is entertaining enough
that I don't watch Spectre or something
instead of watching your website for 12
pound how does this happen what's going
on here how do we fill up that web why
is that happening all the time I think
it's because we keep projecting we
attack the cheapest remember we're
technically proficient we know our stuff
about computers we're being we have
interest in change in upgrades a new
browser comes out we download that thing
and your operating system comes out
unless it's OS X we uploaded immediately
I don't know is it same with you like as
soon as that the news is out the other
one becomes really unstable I don't know
what they're doing but fair enough we
have interest in spending money on the
web and for web services because we're
actually we live off the web so we also
spend money on there and we expect our
audience to do the same thing they
always have the newest computers they
always upgrade the operating system they
make every security patch out there and
that's basically why we have such a
wonderful symbiosis with our users and
we never hate them the reality is kind
of different first of all the last thing
the interest in spending money on the
web for web services doesn't apply to us
because we want everything for free we
all have ad blockers installed because
we're not stupid you know the other
people are the ones that click on ads
you know like why would I do that I love
that Adblock Plus has been bought by
somebody and nobody knows who and that's
that was like four months ago it could
be the Mafia it could be the Triads it
could be NSA or worse the American
government anybody could have bought
these things and that's on all of our
computers and spies on us because we
don't want to see ads I think it's time
for a reality check this is us in the
middle of it we don't spend money but
we're technically proficient we're
interested in change we upgrade all the
time we work for an assumed audience
that actually spend money on the stuff
that we do and keep upgrading their
computers all the time and know what a
computer is and know that a database
error on the page is not their problem
but our problem in reality our audience
is more or less there because it's a
numbers game it's the people the people
that we never see are the people that
click on ads the people that we never
see are the ones that download a new
game where you put two colors and
colorful fluffy things together that
make a ping sound that cost you twelve
dollars those are the people that pay
for the web and it's not i'm not saying
that they're not that they're stupid you
just don't care and even more so they
don't care nowadays anymore because
internet and computers has become
plumbing and water it's become a thing
that's just their people don't know what
offline is or they don't know what a
computer but what a browser is they just
click on the thing and go somewhere on
the mobile phone the browsers to last
app did you open when you
new board of all the other ones the next
users though are not those who complain
that the web is not as good as native
apps Bruce Lawson at state of the
browser and some other conferences gave
this great talk ensuring a performant
web for the next billion people where he
shows you numbers about where the growth
is where the next users are the next
real billion of you billion people are
and it's actually in your neighborhood
here like Indonesia India Africa these
are the markets that are coming right
now and these are not the board people
these are the people what the internet
access to the Internet makes a
difference to them where the Internet is
a teacher where the internet is an
education tool where the internet means
that they will have a business or don't
have a business and this is something we
should think about when we start putting
all the cool new technologies into our
products because we like to because
Moore's law stopped working when
hardware and when we hardwired hardware
and software this is the phone that my
hotel gives me here for free and for
some reason calls me mr. Batchelor I
don't know why it's an android phone
that has a sim card in here that I can
use off in this great service thank you
so much but this Android gave me like
flashbacks from a google i/o six years
ago or something because it's a really
really old small device that never has
been upgraded because it cannot be
upgraded because it's too slow for a
newer Android version and the browser in
there is something that is like done by
fullmoon by two werewolves and an old
Fork of WebKit or something that it just
shouldn't be in use but this is the
browser and will stay the brita browser
of those till the end of time and
everybody who goes into that hotel would
get that browser and there's nothing we
can do about that we can stand on our
ahead and scream that they should have 2
News coolest thing because i want to
have service workers but these phones
are out there and it will stay out there
for quite a while because we hardwired
operating system and browser which is
too stupid idea to Microsoft in the 90s
but now finally gave up as well as
developers we are always asked to do the
impossible that's our problem as well
because we're still so far removed from
the people who pay us money or from the
people who run the projects that we're
doing they always ask us things that we
cannot do in which is too proud to tell
them that we can't do them we just say
okay yeah fair enough I can do that make
it work the same in every browser
that's pointless that's like saying make
your car drive the same speed under
water doesn't analyze on the motorway a
good website looks different and works
different according to the environment
that it's actually used in that's the
power of the web that's the power we
have over native environments make it
easy to maintain and we want to control
everything it's like we want to have a
CMS but we also want to control the
color of every different letter on in
our logo please then what that's where
it becomes complex again make sure that
it's accessible I think there's a law we
need to follow nobody cares about
accessibility because of people they
just don't want to get sued and that's a
cynical argument but I've seen in far
too often sadly enough don't spend too
much time on it let's release it now and
fix it later that's the biggest life
followed by I read the Terms and
Conditions fix it later never comes fix
it later means you put things on the web
that you're embarrassed about and you
will never get the chance to fix use
this analytics code you have no clue
about we need to know how people use our
products like great that your javascript
is fast here's 12 Nana lytic speak ins
that really really slow down the thing
just find the right bricks and assemble
something great there's so many tools
out there 150,000 mpm modules why do you
even write code any longer right what
does this code do
it looks quite complex it looks quite
amazing it's minified of course that's a
good thing any guess it's to follow me
on twitter button this is the code that
is on the Twitter website to copy and
paste so it's progressively enhancing a
link so that's pretty cool but this is
the co degenerates and this is not
because Twitter hates users this is
because Twitter needs to make this thing
work in every environment possible and
just don't want to think about it and
put like lots of poly fields and all
kind of things in there and this is just
painful you know this is like if that's
where we are then we forgot to move the
platform with us and we forgot to feed
back to browsers what we really really
need the amazing tech of today is the
rubbish of tomorrow and I say I see that
a lot right now because working for
microsoft and working on edge we have
this wonderful site scanning tool that
one you put your website in and it shows
you what you're doing wrong with your
website that you're using WebKit only
CSS that using jQuery 12 times where
four times would be enough that you're
using a attached event that's not
necessary anymore of course
addeventlistener works on every browser
nowadays it's a really nice tool to make
to show enterprises and show companies
what they're doing wrong with their
website it's also on get up so if you
find a bug in it or you want to run it
run it behind your firewall as a lot of
our clients are doing you can do that I
think my favorite quote that I heard
from all the clients was a simple way to
detect her older part of our massive
website is it's checking which version
of jQuery was used in that part of it
it's like rings new tree trunk so they
found like 16 different versions of
jQuery on death website because
different departments build different
parts of their website and didn't talk
to each other and didn't point to some
CDN hosted a jQuery that could be that
could be cached and could be evergreen
but everybody just bundled it in and and
threw it in there because nobody sees
that right we break the web for the sake
of developer convenience this is the
experience that the web gives me a lot
like waiting for randoms
off and when there was a javascript
error in the background and they don't
have an event handler of the error case
this is this is forever and ever and
until I reload the page and thought it
was my browser or something like that
how many tutorials do you see where it's
only the success case the error case is
the most important thing this is where
you piss people off you make it as poss
never blame the user for something like
that never let them wait endlessly show
them like something went wrong your data
is safe we're trying again it's our
fault sorry for this this is the only
thing that you can do here but we always
get like well they will reload it don't
worry about that there's a great read
and talk video by Paul by what's his
name again Paul Lewis from google it was
at full frontal last week and the post
was like three days ago it's the cost of
frameworks and it's all about ergonomics
versus user needs and i found that
exciting to talk to him about that
because i had these things before he
collect a lot of data about these
problems so one thing he looked at is
that everybody uses a virtualization and
uses a framework because the dome is
slow but tom is terrible we need a
jquery course Adam was impossible to use
and reading and writing from your HTML
all the time is slowing things down in
the reactor documentation it says the
bottleneck is almost always the Dom
mutation and not the JavaScript
execution so Paul Lewis said like okay
let's let's throw that to a test and see
what's coming out there so you build
this website using angular and using
react that just loads pictures from
twitter from flickr and each of these
pictures like five dom elements because
that's the documentation of the ority
description stand the link and then he
started looking a started a timer when
the page loads until the framework kicks
in and then he finishes the timer and
then it starts writing out the HTML and
starting to position the pictures and
stuff and then the second time of
finishes and what he found out what's
really interesting that the more
pictures you have the longer of course
it takes we all know that more HTML not
a good idea but what he found is that
the the rendering and the dom
manipulation stayed more or less the
same whereas the javascript execution
framework that reads all these things
and then turns them into virtualized
Stallman writes them out there it's
becoming bigger and bigger like 1.5
seconds at the end of it when it came to
like 100 1,000,000 dot no 1500 pictures
on a 50,000 picture something like that
anyways he realized that the Dom
manipulation is slow but it stays the
same whereas the JavaScript execution if
you do clever things to your things
before you render them out becomes
bigger and bigger because the objects
internally take more memory it takes
more computation these kind of things he
even found more interestingly that when
you do vanilla JavaScript without the
library the more pictures who did it
started evening out and it started
actually becoming faster again because
the browser caches stuff for you the
JavaScript engine reuses things that are
already being there like okay I notice I
don't have to touch it anymore because
it hasn't changed where it's like doing
clever things in your library means like
you start from scratch every single time
again so we need to learn in these
libraries to do the same kind of caching
if you read the same Dom element in
jQuery 16 times it should come from a
cache and not be read from document
again but this is very interesting that
we optimize the JavaScript engines 40s
end cases and we don't get these end
cases any longer because people think
JavaScript engines are too slow from the
very beginning and they're not browsers
to an incredibly amount of work for us
and we always just complain when
something is broken if you think about
it and you work your work with browser
makers they display all kind of media
content like how many images out there
are in the wrong format with the wrong
file name in the wrong mime type and the
browser will still show them people can
put bitmap bmps on the web and the
browser will render them instead of
hurting those people which would be the
right thing to do it fixes minor
mistakes in our code you don't close a P
tag the browser closes it for you we
gave up on developers we just expect you
to do mistakes and the browser should
fix it for us and this is called like a
good programming nowadays or something
we optimize our code to run smoothly the
amount of stuff that you chakra
JavaScript engine does two for loops by
Lou by reading through them in
seeing if there's a function called and
embed that function into the other one
before creating a binary code from them
is quite impressive it provides us with
developer tools we have full inside over
what we're doing but we're still
complaining it's probably the browser
that slow and it's very easy to point
out that was our mistake and it was just
bad rendering thrashing of the layout
again a young kind of things because of
that they provide us with deep insights
what our code does to the computer we
cap heap analysis how much RAM we used
how much CPU were using when i started
with javascript i had not even idea what
the cpu would be like I couldn't even
tested in the operating systems back
then but now we have it in the browsers
it allows us to automate testing on them
and debug remotely on devices we don't
even own we can use third-party services
like browser tests and browser link and
all these kind of things to access a
iphone in America and that connectivity
and get the report back how our
JavaScript amazed they perform their how
awesome is that and and yet we want to
have every browser on our machine and
tested there rather than just using
these kind of wonderful environments
Paul build a great thing called big rig
which takes a which takes at a scanner
file either from chrome or from
webpagetest org and it shows you what
was going on how much memory was
consumed what the CPU was doing where
your time went and where your
computation went and using this you can
actually tweak your applications and
realize where the real bottlenecks are
instead of just complaining about that
it's the Dom I was very interesting use
the to do MVC application and then use
different libraries and compared them
with each other how much they're in size
and how much then bootstrap time and on
a 95 in an iphone 5s and he found out
that some of them took up to two seconds
before they started rendering the first
line and this is all JavaScript
execution this is not like talking to
the browser and all kind of things this
is the deed libraries themselves because
we want to use them and it makes it
easier for us as developers but these
are two seconds and lots of battery and
lots of time on useless machines that
they shouldn't have to use because we
want to write three lines of JavaScript
instead of car instead of 50 it's not
about how many lines
javascript your itís how your code
behaves at the end users computer
because these are the people we work for
we don't work for other developers
unless you write developer tools we work
for people out there and they shouldn't
have phones that the battery dies
because we have a memory leak in the
background fixing everything with a lot
of JavaScript helps us but not
necessarily our audience javascript has
become this duct tape of the web leg if
something's wrong we do with javascript
because then we got full control over it
and we don't not at the mercy of those
stupid browsers and those terrible
environments we just can do everything
ourselves because we're infallible and
we're domestic levers people on the
planet we all know that so we should
worry about oops we should worry a lot
more about costs and costs and Paul
talked about this as well costs for
developers is learning new frameworks
like every month there's a new one and
we want to have it on our CV so we have
to look at it and then version 2 is
completely completely different to
version 1 so we have to relearn them and
find out what changed and why is it
breaking out of a sudden because
frameworks is software as well it's the
same problems that we have its people
writing these things debugging
frameworks where did this error come
from it's obviously not in my code but
the framework does something wrong so
can you debug the framework do you
understand what the thing is doing or do
you just have to wait until there's a
patch and you'd go back to your client
well we have to wait three weeks sorry
about that I hope you can pay us for the
three weeks we're not doing anything
setting up developer environments so
it's like this is easy you're at a
command line type Keys 12 things in wait
for 15 minutes of em p.m. with 12 with
200 warnings and then everything will be
fine or like oh you need you need a
macbook pro to run this JavaScript no no
sorry and cutting down on possible hires
and adding two on boarding time if your
company subscribed to I 02 I don't know
a blah blah framework so and so you only
can hire people that are happy to use
blah blah framework so and so and you
actually cut down on those feet but
doesn't work most of time are the more
expensive ones as well the real
important bit is the cost for our
end-users time to load and execute the
bandwidths used you remember 66 pound
per megabyte CPU
search the frame rate if it's less than
60 frames per seconds and we had that in
the first talk today it feels icky
people will complain that it's not fast
no matter how fast it really is memory
usage because memory is not endless as
well and that actually ties into battery
life as well if your website sucks my
battery dry that's not a good service
it's time to clean up and learn the
basics I love that BYE MOM now to post
yesterday find meaningless code why was
it put their future proofing rip out the
code the future is here and it's not
happy with your proofing we are crap at
predicting the future we really are if
we were we could play the lottery and
don't have to work anymore but all of
our code or a clever code predicts
problems of the future wait until the
problems are there and write code for
now that is fast small and behaves
really well on our end users computers
worry about the problems that are coming
with scale when they're coming there's
nothing worse that when you have lots of
users and it gets slowed that's a good
problem to have because those users pay
money then you actually get paid to fix
these things rather than hoping the
future will come the JavaScript learning
process has always been kind of
interesting what do we do we use view
source to see what other people are
doing then we copy and paste the bits
that look like they're responsible for
some things then we change some numbers
around we run into errors and we blame
Internet Explorer that was back then no
of course now we're all like full stack
developers and whatever we call
ourselves right now so be much more
professional so nowadays we search for a
solution on stack overflow we copy and
paste the bits that look like they're
responsible for some things we change
some numbers around we run into errors
and we blame JavaScript for being a
terrible and not a real language and we
blame Internet Explorer for good measure
we're running out of both excuses first
of all internet explorer is dead Windows
10 is the operating system there's a
free upgrade the browser's evergreen
like all the others i love that at the
MVP summit unattended laptops will be
upgraded to windows 10 javascript grew
up as well es6 is here it's a ratified
standard we as 2016 2015 is not es6 is
rat
I'd since June we have a standard and
it's not the what is javascript anymore
it's ECMO script six is the is here and
it's backwards compatible and has a lot
of good changes in it the support is
encouraging we got edge Firefox Chrome
Safari on is on iOS 9 Safari is really
really good and that's uncommon because
a lot of other things Safari is like not
as good any longer and they're not as
fast as implementing us because reasons
there's a compatibility table at Kang X
website is really really good for
finding out what's going on some numbers
edge is eighty percent Firefox 4271
percent chrome is sixty-three percent
Android twenty-nine percent and
fifty-four percent so a lot of stuff you
can use one hundred percent is not
possible to achieve right now because a
few of the standard bits would break a
wrist already existing functionality we
found websites that run all version of
mood tools for example and we cannot use
array contains in our JavaScript engine
because of deaths because it would break
old websites browser innovation also
means don't break the web because we are
not allowed to do that but we as
developers broke the web by using things
too early now with year six we have a
clean new slate and the new baseline is
here i love that by kyle symes in the
other day a new baseline for modern
JavaScript competency includes
understanding how to effectively use
promises generators for a sync up your
game and I don't know up your game I
think about these like bros drinking
beer when I hear that kind of stuff I'm
very allergic to this you know I'm like
we're in high school trying to impress
each other how much more JavaScript we
know our JavaScript knowledge should
make better products for our end users
that's the main reason everything else
is a nice to have everything else is
unnecessary and if if you write better
code and faster code by using all these
things good for you but other than that
as he as you said like as well I'm
trying to turn over a new leaf or
encourage people to less Nick the
negativity I won't fully succeed but I'm
trying and then like it's just the face
of burnout because if we if we up each
other all the time we like this is what
we have to use we're burning out and for
nothing and we're not burning out for
creating better things for our end users
we're burning up by trying to
one another who's going to be the best
JavaScript developer on this planet you
know when people come up to me and
select do you think that guys better
than you and I'm not maybe I don't care
I want to be better tomorrow than I'm
here denim today I'm comparing myself
with myself and then I can overtake
anybody else if I compare myself with
other people all the time I just get
frustrated there's a lot of frustration
going on in our market controlled
environments allow us to use the newest
and coolest and find best practices so
if you're using server side JavaScript
and you're running node make that work
across all platforms any node solution
that only works on mac is terrible you
might as well right right native code
and use everything you can find in es6
that you want to use and use it to the
best practice in the right patterns in
the node environment because you control
it for example vs code was released
yesterday open source it's running on
node so play with that hack type thing
to death find something cool in there
Adam editor we saw that earlier as well
these are the environments where we can
play because we control them this is our
stuff so let's play with the newest and
coolest inside of those but don't play
for end users because they cannot use it
let's not make JavaScript wrote the
world overly complex and scary this is
the entrance to my dental office in
London I don't know why I'm going there
but it's really like a horror movie but
you saw that earlier we don't we
shouldn't shock people with what they
need to do if they want to write
javascript is 6 7 2015 2029 caters to
different audiences each of these parts
are either for syntactic sugar for the
jQuery users for scalable applications
of a library builders you don't need to
know all of it and you don't need to
feel depressed if you don't know what a
symbol means because you will not use it
if you don't write a library for example
you do will not use it if you don't
write a massive application but you can
have used templates for the things that
make sense to you play with it and find
out which parts matter to you and start
loving those parts start kicking the
tires of those parts start writing good
things with those parts rather than just
like oh I should have used that one as
well because people say so people say a
lot of stupid things don't listen to
people phas allows you to learn and use
it in the now so that one converts you
is 62 is 5 so it runs every
we're performance issue you don't know
what you're controlling but it's great
to learn es6 right now because you can
run it on any device and you see what's
actually coming out of it you can see
what HTML file but what-what es5 gets
generated from your es6 pony foo has a
great has a great order so long that's
wrong link excellent I'm es6 overview
and 350 bullet points if you really want
to have like chunky bits go damn if you
want to read a book that's exploring
your six-pack so Roush Maya its online
for free or it costs like twenty dollars
to buy I was one of the editors it's an
amazing book it's a really really
beautiful explanation not only how but
also the why why were things done in a
certain way in es6 and not like okay
this is it you have to use it now but
also let's just calm down a bit and fix
and remove what's broken on the web
because there's so many things broken
out there I'm just we have two megabyte
everywhere 170 things so what's going on
there let's fix those as well let's
analyze and clean up put the web on a
diet and 12 convenient solution at a
time kill those old libraries because we
don't need them any longer they're just
dead weight on the web right now and
then the helping hand what I'm doing
right now when I'm feeling depressed I
go to github and a look at something
that's kind of broken and I fix it and
then I send it send a request and say
like okay I fixed this because this is
the reasons why I think this is better
you might get a bit get a response back
you know right thats words my code what
the hell doesn't matter you still learn
something from it but you might be lucky
and you might get something like me the
other day when i'm like thanks very much
for your input advice on making the
changes i learned something new today I
appreciate it take care and this feels
good and it's what we should do to each
other much much more rather than
outbidding each other on who's the
coolest javascript developer of tomorrow
and a JavaScript warrior of the world so
let's turn education as competition into
education and fun again and now that you
don't have to be perfect you can be good
that's all I had so thanks very much
yea high priest thanks for your talk I I
appreciate and I agree everything is big
excellent yeah and and while grid we as
um Kim presenter just now as well that
we developers we also have the tendency
of over engineering things and and
Kenley in delivering product and focused
too much on maybe performance and how
will you suggest us to balance between
these are these two things so the
question was to how do we how do we find
how do we stop ourselves from over from
over architecting and from thinking too
much about performance I think you can't
think too much about performance if it
means the performance of your end users
if it means the thing will run better on
the end machine that's great put as much
as time as you want in there and I'd
rather us work a week longer on a
product that is good for our end users
then to release it and say like where
the fastest engineers out there when it
comes to over architecting our things
and talking about the future is what I
said about we try to predict things of
the future that will come I'd rather
have a clean code that is easy to
understand then have a very generic code
that can deal with every situation out
there because this generic code will be
used to ten percent of what it can do in
most of the cases so I think if you find
that you're using only a part of what
you've written then you have wasted a
lot of time at the same time to release
it as a JavaScript library and when how
can use for a day that makes us excited
performance is the most important thing
in terms of what our end users have
performance of us as developers how much
code can we turn out in a month is what
made us what made the web so broken
right now it's not about how much code
we write its how much clever code we
write how much our code does to our end
users and that also means we have to
communicate much more with other
departments where I found ourselves
architecting wrongly as well is that we
think as developers we have to do
everything I found for example paper
prototyping when Yahoo made us go
through like
five iterations of a tool before we
actually build it and we spent the time
that people spend paid a paper
prototyping with end users to write the
data API is instead so parallel work on
different parts of the interface is a
very important thing we can only do that
when we start communicating with other
parts of our company and not only do
everything in engineering talking to
humans I know it's scary but it's a good
thing something will come out of it and
so kind of you say that we shouldn't
focus on life was too shiny new
framework but if um how do you convince
companies that even if you don't know
framework X you're a very good developer
mmm that is a really good question so
companies won't want you to see the
newest and coolest all the time and they
measure the quality of developers that
way and I think that's where the whole
hype thing went pear-shaped in terms of
like in terms of how do you convince
companies you show them how much you
really know about the basics you you
shouldn't just guard new frameworks that
you don't need them you should know what
they are and you should know how what
use case is there in if you come to an
interview and they say look well what do
you think about react and you say like
for this kind of application that kind
of stuff and that kind of things it's a
really good idea whereas most of the
time I would go for this kind of
solution because then it performs better
any hiring manager who has half a brain
would be very excited about that answer
so getting found in LinkedIn is a
different story but that's also the jobs
that you normally don't get I think one
of my favorite moments was when I hired
a javascript engineer in in Mozilla I
know in yahoo begged them we gave people
a drop an exercise a website to build
which is illegal in California but in
England we could do it and the
javascript parts of it were kind of
tricky liver they looked very simple but
I had a few mistakes in them and these
kind of things and the guy who came in
had used all the examples from my
javascript book and he didn't know that
I'm the guy interviewing JavaScript
developers so he came into the room and
he was as wide as the wall when I came
in he's like oh my god I'm like yeah i
saw that code and i kind of looks
familiar and he's like yeah it's from
your book and like what didn't you like
about my code and what would you what
would you make to better and the
explained that I hired him
spot there's no problem using code when
you understand it when you don't
understand and you try to impress people
by listing five different modules and
hoping they don't understand it either
then we have a communication problem so
understanding how much you use things
for is something that more and more
companies will look forward to as well
when we get or less excited about hiring
50 developers because company growth is
something that TechCrunch loves all
right I think we can close it here big
hands for Chris and thank you so much
for coming all the way out here